es ist Sommer und ich könnte den ganzen
Tag lang nur grillen aber eine Sache
muss man leider sagen grillen ist teuer
weil man kauft gutes Fleisch fancy Dips
was auch immer grillen ist nicht die
günstigste Art und Weise sich zu
ernähren oder wir werden heute mit 10 €
einkaufen fahren und gucken ob wir einen
gesamten Tag dafür grillen können aber
nicht irgendwie einfach billig einkaufen
und dann reinhauen nein wir werden
kreative Gerichte machen frische
Gerichte machen und auch nichts
verzichten also gehen wir einkaufen oder
jetzt bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt ob
wir das schaffen hier ist nicht viel
aber ich glaube türkische Supermarkt ist
ein guter Trick wir wissen ja nicht mal
was hier kaufen wollen
oder Spiegelei das wird geil Hähnchen
mit so einem leichten Salat Kartoffeln
kriegt man nicht immer einzelne Zwiebeln
Schalotten
Süßkartoffeln
aber kaufen Mario
selber machen
[Gelächter]
Kilo Tomaten 1 Euro das ist geil schauen
wir jetzt mal Bulgur da gibt es ja auch
verschiedene
groben
500 Gramm
maximum
nicht
so brutal wenn wir das später gehen das
Wasser wirklich im Mund zusammenlaufen
sieht gut aus
[Musik]
1,47€. eine unglaubliche Vielfalt die
nicht 10 € und 16 Cent gekostet hat es
tut mir leid Leute ich habe es nicht
ganz geschafft heute aber ich hätte zum
Beispiel nie gedacht ein Maiskolben 1,50
€, das ist schon echt schwer aber
vielleicht hat es nicht ich glaube wenn
ich ein zwei Sachen anders gekauft hätte
wäre ich auch irgendwie unter die zehn
Euro bekommen Tomaten Zwiebeln Eier
Bulgur Kartoffel Gurke Zuckermais
Hirtenkäse also die Vielfalt ist da das
Essen wird lecker aber eine weitere
Sache habe ich noch mitgebracht und ich
finde es sehr passend dass wir jetzt
gerade hier in meiner Küche zu Hause
stehen wo alles angefangen hat ihr seht
vor mir ihr kennt natürlich auch das
Logo das hinter mir leuchtet in der
Studio Küche Block und viele von euch
haben sich gefragt was ist das Ganze ich
sage euch so viel es ist meine Antwort
darauf was man auf jeden Fall in der
Küche haben sollte ich habe viele Videos
gedreht in den ich bei verschiedenen
Leuten in der Küche war und manche
Sachen haben wir immer gefehlt das sind
sie drei Produkte an der Zahl mit denen
wir starten ich glaube das könnte eine
Reise werden die noch ein bisschen
länger geht und ich will es euch hier
direkt face to face einfach mal zeigen
was wir alles haben hier haben wir
einmal eine Salz Boxen Leute die Leute
haben ja auch schon geschrieben hey was
ist Block was ist in den Kommentaren
oder wo kriege ich dieses Brett von
Block die Antwort steht hier auf Block
Punkt Shop und zwar am 7.7 weitere Infos
findet ihr auf Instagram Preise alles
drum und dran guck da vorbei ich bin
sehr sehr stolz darauf und ich sage euch
wirklich das sind Produkte die wenn ihr
sie noch nicht kennt euren koch-alltag
bereichern Punkt nicht mehr und nicht
weniger da könnt ihr Salz reinfüllen
natürlich auch andere Gewürze einfach
aufschnacken zu machen ich persönlich
kannte bis dato keine Methode um schön
und elegant zu salzen immer eine schönen
Prise nehmen Blogs craper auch nicht
wegzudenken forey Leute ein Schaber ist
so wichtig und das weiß man erst wenn
man einen benutzt hat der hier ist geil
Akazienholz wie bei den anderen
Produkten auch schön angeschärft damit
könnt ihr auch ein bisschen was aufheben
können sogar mal was kaputt hacken das
heißt dafür ist auch perfekt jetzt das
große Paket vielleicht habt ihr schon
Vorahnen nicht wegzudenken richtig schön
groß und nicht irgendwie ihr seht mich
immer damit arbeiten innen drin ist eine
Auffangschale Ofen fest viel Platz
deswegen sagen guckt euch die Website an
überzeugt mich von dem Produkten alle
weiteren Infos findet ihr auf Instagram
Block vom Shop oder im Newsletter auf
der website-block Shop tragt euch ein
Kochen ja achso und warum Block
vielleicht wusstet ihr jetzt nicht heißt
Kolben mit Nachnamen und einfach erst
umgedreht Kolb fand ich irgendwie cool
das erste Gericht und alles was wir
brauchen eine Kartoffel Zwiebel Eier
bisschen Olivenöl Salz Petersilie und
ein paar Gewürze wir machen breakfast
potatoes und die habe ich auch tiktok
gesehen sehen brutal aus legen wir
direkt los erstmal schneiden wir uns
scheibenvorteil wenn wir das ganze in
kleine Würfel schneiden das Garten
gleichmäßig gerade schön schnell vor
allem weil so eine Kartoffel ohne
vorkochen ist eigentlich bisschen crazy
das ist immer aber so funktioniert das
auf jeden Fall wenn man es ganz genau
nimmt könnte man die hier jetzt quasi
Weg tun aber ich schmeißt natürlich
nicht weg ab hier haben wir dann
perfekte Würfel alle perfekt
gleichförmig auch ne ja das machst du
wirklich perfekt perfekt
ist weil unser Tisch eigentlich aus drei
Kästen besteht
Alter guckt euch das mal an mehr als
genug Kartoffeln für einen sehr
reichhaltiges Frühstück ich gehe mit ein
bisschen Salz dran
[Musik]
jetzt können wir direkt schon ein
bisschen Öl auf unsere geben ihr wisst
wenn wir on budget einkaufen sind so
Sachen wie Salz oder Öl nicht mit einem
Rechner erstmal die Kartoffeln drauf
[Musik]
als nächstes können wir uns um die
Zwiebel wenn ihr das nicht und Budget
macht euch noch Knoblauch ein bisschen
Bacon das auf jeden Fall brutales
Gericht Zwiebel einfach in Würfel
schauen wir mal wie die Kartoffeln
Aussehen schon ordentlich Farbe dran das
sieht schon ziemlich gut aus jetzt gebe
ich einmal meine Zwiebel hinzu einfach
oben drauf funktioniert natürlich auch
auf dem Herd Leute was soll ich das
gesagt sein oder mit einer gusseisern
Platte auf dem Grill Gewürze daran ein
bisschen Paprika bisschen Cayenne hat
aber die Kartoffeln nehmen schön die
Farbe auch von den Gewürzen an ne so
klein vielleicht zehn Minuten waren
jetzt auf dem Grill wenn ich schon gut
sind aber schneller als kochen
am kleinen bisschen bis ein zwei Minuten
vielleicht noch aber noch einen guten
Weg keiner sagen dass das mit der
Situation für eine Person sein soll oder
das ist so ein komplettes Blech die
Kartoffeln sehen gut ausgeben auf
unseren Teller
zur Seite was unsere Pflanze noch mal
heiß werden und machen uns noch zwei
schöne Spiegel ja ja
[Musik]
was soll ich euch sagen Leute ein
wunderschönes Frühstück das auf jeden
Fall wir haben diese Kartoffelwürfel
unten die wirklich perfekt durchgegart
sind oben drauf zwei schöne Spiegeleier
bisschen Petersilie auch fürs Auge
wirklich ein hübsches Frühstück muss ich
sagen probieren wir erstmal die Würfel
vielleicht sogar die schnellste Art und
Weise Kartoffeln lecker zuzubereiten
also wirklich verdammt schnell dazu das
perfekte Spiegelei wie so eine kleine
Creme dazu
das als Frühstück vom Grill Hammer nice
hätte auch in dem 1 Euro Gerichte Rezept
Video sein können nicht weniger kreativ
wird es aber beim Mittagessen aber wenn
ich das gegessen habe brauche erstmal
ein bisschen aber wir sehen uns gleich
wieder wenn es heißt ab an den Grill
kommen wir zum Mittagessen wir machen
hähnchenkotelett mit einem schönen
Bulgursalat Bulgur habe ich hier drin
ungefähr die Hälfte von dem Glas ich
schütte also die doppelte Menge heißes
Wasser ein und schönes oben drauf so
dass der Bulgur etwas mehr als bedeckt
ist jetzt kann ich schon mit ein
bisschen Salz dran gehen einmal
durchrühren und wir decken das ganze ab
zum Quellen für 10 Minuten keine Ahnung
bisschen fertig sind als nächstes habe
ich hier mein Hähnchen komplett somit
das beste was man kaufen kann wenn man
ohne Budget ist aber trotzdem was sehr
leckeres haben möchte für die Leute die
nicht wissen was das ist ein
Hähnchenkeule ausgelöst jetzt gehe ich
mit einer kräutergrill Mischung dran und
einfach das was ihr gerade zu Hause
haben das heißt und ich gehe mit der
Hautseite zuerst drauf
dann wird die Haut schon knusprig ich
mache das ganze nicht über den normalen
Grill weiß sonst total schnell anfängt
zu brennen weil das so viel Fett Mini
Salatgurke vorne hinten ab kannst du
einmal halbiert und damit sie uns nicht
verbessert holen wir in der Mitte weil
sie das Innenleben einmal raus auch geil
um zum Beispiel in joghurtd rein zu
machen oder sowas aber das ist alles
nicht in unserem Budget das schneide ich
das ganze hier so in Stifte die ist dann
wiederum klein schneiden kann das haben
wir wieder Platz für die Tomate die
schneiden wir uns in Scheiben auch hier
wieder viel mehr als wir brauchen
wichtig natürlich alles Seiten jedes
Bestandteil von Salat ja alles nach was
schmecken ne zum Salat dazu die Frische
aus riecht frisch Petersilie an sich von
gerade noch geschnitten und die haben so
viel übrig jetzt breche ich da einfach
die Hälfte von unserem filterkäse noch
grob mit rein ich finde wenn man das so
hört Gurken Tomaten Feta Salat mit
Bulgur und Hähnchen komplett denkt man
nicht dass wir gerade in dem Budge
bisschen Olivenöl dran gucken wir noch
unseren
ordentlich gequollen aber kann noch ein
bisschen Zähnchen wirklich sehr perfekt
geworden schöne Kruste schön
durchgebraten hier fehlt nur noch ich
gebe dir jetzt einfach drauf
das ist wirklich das perfekte Sommer
Mittagessen zwei Personen wieder und
wieder ohne Budget guckt was soll ich
sagen jetzt hat gesehen ich finde es
sieht verdammt gut aus Mama mir wirklich
ein sehr sehr schönes Stück Hähnchen
schön durchgebraten schön saftig
einfach
saftig fertig geschmacksintensiv dazu
unser bürgersalat die schöne dicke
Tomate
Gurke Petersilie Hirtenkäse wow das ist
wirklich wieder zu gut ungünstig zu sein
[Musik]
gegessen habt nach diesem Video müsste
es einmal probieren Maiskolben Öl Ei
Petersilie und Tahin dazu noch ein
bisschen Väter wir machen Lotte liebe
ich übertrieben mexikanische Maiskolben
schön dunkel gegrillt dazu eine schöne
Mayonnaise die wir selbst machen los
geht's auf kann richtig heiß sein dafür
wir gehen hier auf die sison Schlag
einfach ein Ei auf 100 ml Öl und wir
machen die einfachste Mayonnaise der
Welt selbst warum weil es günstiger ist
dass sie zu kaufen Salz und Pfeffer zu
Öl und Ei wichtig wie immer bei Mario
alle Zutaten müssen die gleiche
Temperatur an das funktioniert das mit
dem irgendwoieren manchmal nicht so gut
langsam hochziehen
fertig ist unsere Kühlschrank bis wir
gleich anrichten damit noch ein bisschen
kühler wird interessant das ist wirklich
ein bisschen wie Popcorn was hier gerade
abgeht durch die hohe Hitze platzen die
manchmal so ein bisschen auf aber wir
kriegen auch diese schöne Farbe dran das
ist schon wirklich brutal am liebsten
natürlich noch mit ein bisschen Limette
kostet jetzt zu viel wir machen das mit
dem limettenseits mit
funktioniert auch Grill aus Maiskolben
rüber so wir gehen jetzt unsere Mayo
über den Maiskolben streichen die ein
bisschen ein so dass sie quasi in die
Zwischenräume einzieht von unserem Mais
wie soll das nicht schmecken das ist
Mais süß schön mit einer cremigen Mayo
oben drüber kein Filter wegen Budget
aber es schmeckt auf jeden Fall sehr gut
rein sonst tut es auch Limette oder Salz
Petersilie Original ist es Koriander
hübsch schnelle selbstgemachte Mayo wenn
ihr da habt oder was anderes
kostengünstig schnell farbenfrohung und
lecker Rennen
man sieht mir an dass das gut ist lecker
cremig limettennote frische wenn man
alle Gerichte zeigen würde und Leute
fragen würde wie viel Geld haben wir
dafür bezahlt
niemals 10 Euro ihr habt gesehen dass
man für 10 € wirklich sehr gut essen
kann sogar von Grillen vielleicht kann
ich euch inspirieren wenn ihr was nach
macht dann tagt mich blocken Job ihr
wisst Bescheid guck da vorbei 18 Uhr 7
macht's gut und vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen